so hi I'm schillers I've heard your PhD
student in computational neuroscience
and today I want to give you some habits
that I really felt have changed my
coding and programming game so I come
from a background of physics and
especially theoretical physics so we
didn't really do any programming when I
was in my bachelor's it was mainly just
deriving mathematical equations and
although I do think now it's really
useful I did really have to speed learn
how to program in different languages
such as python Matlab C plus plus and
now are to be able to do the PHD that
I'm doing right now and one of the
things that I think that programmers
apart from other people from other
fields is really the mindset of a
programmer and I think to cultivate the
mindset of a programmer I have created
this list of five habits that can help
you get to this mindset so let's get
straight into it so the first thing is
practice I think the most important
thing in programming is that you
practice it every day I almost see
programming as a kind of sport and you
don't get better at any type of sport
unless you play it every day so
something that has really helped me to
create this programming habits such that
I do it every day is the idea of tiny
habits so tiny habits is kind of this
behavioral change method that places
emphasis on beginning with modest and
doable goals that may be quickly
incorporated into a person's daily
routine the concept is that if these
tiny behaviors are constantly carried
out they will eventually result in a
development of larger more significant
habits over time this strategy is
founded on the idea that making tiny
gradual improvements over time can be
more sustainable than trying to make
massive abrupt changes all at once so I
think the idea of creating a tiny habit
and creating programming tiny habit is
really valuable so to be able to do this
the first thing you have to do is start
small so instead of thinking about
loading as this massive task that you
have to achieve all at once try to
choose one tiny task that you could do
every day so for example that's or
creating a tiny programming assignments
for example if you're following 100 days
of python code I think every day they
have a tiny assignment that you could
achieve every day or for example by
reading a little bit on stack Overflow
or improving one part of your
programming skills you can have this
tiny implementable behavior that you
could do every day the second part is to
choose a specific time so when I was
learning how to program I always have my
mornings free for programming so every
day every morning I would wake up and
immediately start on some kind of tiny
programming task and it could be that I
had a little bit more time that day and
I would continue until the afternoon or
it could be that I only had one hour and
I would only do one hour of programming
every morning and the third thing is
also to set reminders so something that
I like to do when I'm really working
towards this goal is for example to use
a habit tracker so one that I really
like is from notion they have these free
habit tracker templates that you can
fill in such that you can see at the end
of the week if you really did every tiny
habit so these kind of little reminders
if you fill this in that you have to do
these tiny habits every day really work
for me the second tip is to read code so
something that I didn't really realize
as a beginner is that there's so much
code written on the internet so a lot of
things that you want to do can be done
in multiple ways so you could write for
example a for Loop in Python but you can
also make this list comprehension which
is just a much shorter way to write a
for Loop and I think by reading others
quote pretty diligently you can kind of
see how they optimize their coding and
actually reading other people's code
will also slowly improve your coding so
if you have some friends that are
working on the same project this is kind
of perfect because then you can kind of
see how they solved their problem first
try to solve it yourself though or if
you don't have these kind of people in
your environment there are also website
online that you can see how other people
solved their coding problems the third
thing which I wish I had done a little
bit earlier during my bachelor's program
and also my masters is the idea of beard
programming so peer program is really
that you work and send them on the same
assignment and I know this is quite
common in companies but I'm not really
sure if they already do this at
University but during my PhD for example
right now I'm working together with one
good friend of mine on the same project
and we sometimes peer program and I
would say she's a lot better of a
programmer than I am she has just been
programming for so much longer and if
you program together with someone in
tandem it is a little bit stressful but
it also increases your skills by tenfold
just because they can correct you
immediately when you make a mistake and
they can also see the way you write
certain code and give you for example
some suggestions so if you have the
possibility to program at the University
you're at I would definitely try to look
into that so my first thing is to read
the latest news I think right now in
programming there's so many new
technologies coming up so for example
programming together with AI where AI
writes part of your code is something
that's really big and coming it's
already been used for example co-pilot
in GitHub but I think in the future it
will just be implemented in any type of
programming language that you program in
tandem with an AI and if you want to go
into the field of programming you really
have to keep up with the latest news and
the latest developments because
otherwise before you know it the skills
you've developed and curated so
carefully over the years are in a
language that are that is no longer used
that much and the last thing or tip that
I have number five is to share with
others what you've learned so I think
this is probably the scariest part and
probably the bit that most people people
skip but I think it's the most important
so sharing the code that you've created
or if you make any type of Project
online allows you to demonstrate the
skills that you have developed and it
also allows others to give you feedback
and review a little bit the code that
you've made so I've noticed that
whenever I put coding projects public on
GitHub that I took the code that I wrote
so much more seriously so for example
when I'm coding in private for myself
just for certain small little projects I
usually write very ugly and very
unreadable code whereas if I know that
other people have to use it in the
future I usually write it in a more
tutorial like style so I put dedicated
comments for future users on how to use
the code and how to understand the code
but by doing this really carefully I
also noticed that I myself start to
understand my own written code so much
better and also if you delicately put it
on a certain website such as GitHub for
example people you will see that in a
few years you will have a really nice
portfolio of several coding projects
that you've made over the years so these
were my tips or habits for becoming a
better programmer and I'm really curious
if you're a programmer yourself how you
have learned it over the years what kind
of tips or habits you have developed
over the years and if you have any
skills or resources you would like to
share so please put it down in the
comments below and otherwise see you
next week bye